Kara.
It was only a couple of months ago.
Tell me.
We were helpless.
Our army threw everything we had at them, but they were unstoppable.
No!
You've seen these before?
A lot of them.
On Krypton?
In Kandor, the capital; the day it disappeared.
A whole city disappeared?
It calls itself Brainiac.
I am flesh and machine.
I am the strength of 10,000 worlds.
These probes must be how he searches for planets.
If that thing is here, it's all going to happen again.
No, we can beat him.
Millions of lives; they all need to be freed.
Go!
You have already failed.
Soon, Earth will be mine.
We'll see about that.
Such a savage world.
It gives me strength.
Welcome to Earth.